you have this fantastic CD out you have
this look at this look at this you have
it on wax as well which is gorgeous on
the Decca label I would think would be
and this is a passion of yours playing
the piano and and you are a sensualist
this is a man who's very tactile
he's essentialist and I'm wondering it
what is it about the piano I've I bet
you you get like a sensual thrill from
playing there playing the piano I do I
do I always like the piano that what I
do I do well you're a fine guitarist of
course I get by but all instrument I
don't I never had the patience the fact
well everything you know the feel of
everything it must be nice to play the
guitar I don't know the guitar but that
must be nice those strings feel like
something on your fingertips the piano
of course you know yeah it's nice to
feel and and and there's almost like
your fingers are doing them because I
notice in everyday life you use your
fingers a lot you're quite expressive
but it must be nice when you're running
your fingers along the piano they're
doing a little dance yeah you know I
mean it is yes not only do I have a
relationship with the piano keys and can
feel what they feel like and that and
the configuration but yes you do like in
the guitar there's shapes that your hand
then makes you're dancing with your hand
and and doing things with hands likewise
like that different shapes and so you're
dancing hey you know I just discovered
so I I'm a late bloomer and I feel like
I'm getting better at things all the
time and I played I went through mime
nothing if not disciplined and I went
through my piano workout today I say I
did better than ever I think I played
better than ever this morning I
discovered something my band with whom I
play eighth degree black belt musicians
they were giving me a kind of some tips
about tapping tapping your foot as you
play and what is you do then I was
playing some things that I knew well and
I wasn't tapping at all and letting just
the rhythm happen in my fingers without
any other hmm just my fingers
and this morning I did that something
happens some more life and
responsibility was delivered to my
fingers and I played better
that's incredible do you ever make
little noises when you put like I do
well jazz cuz some jazz guys famously
you know Keith Jarrett listen to a
recording to Keith Jarrett he's quite
orgasmic and uh he has very well you
know just can I just pitch you like
mm-hmm like a sly cat purring as you
play is that I think sound sounds kind
of come out involuntarily anyway one of
my favorite Peter Liang was Erroll
Garner and he would grunge and do things
yeah I do things yep yep yep there's no
one like you